by the way I've said many times on this
show up in the last six months that this
is a slow-moving COO I once read the
list of things the Trump does that sound
like a third world dictator you put your
name on buildings you point your family
members to positions of power your
rallies are scary you hate the press and
talk about jailing reporters you want
missile parades he doesn't have one but
he wants one you use the office for
financial gain you love other dictators
you lie so freely people can't tell the
difference between truth and lies
anymore I left one out which came to the
floor this week not that it hasn't been
brewing the constant ridiculous
over-the-top flattery that the Dear
Leader needs now in North Korea for
example Kim jong-un they say things like
he he learned to drive at the age of
three really you know this about North
Korea the old man that the father they
said he trained his body so he never
needed to urinate or defecate he
invented the hamburger and still didn't
need to defecate when he was born a new
star was created and winter turned to
spring the first time he played golf
he had 11 holes in one this is us now
this is America this is what is so scary
so you know I see where this is going so
we thought we would institute a new
department here called the ass-kisser of
the month because this is going on in
America
this is just from the last couple of
weeks this is judge Jeanine Pirro our
first nominee our commander in chief the
pillar of strength and a true advocate
for America Fox News commentator carlo
corey lewandowski because he is the
greatest communicator as a president
we've ever had here Scott Pruett
yesterday please know that I'm thankful
for your fortitude your courage and your
steadfastness and this even extends to
other leaders because other foreign
leaders get the message you have to kiss
his ass too getting done listen to
Palestinian President Mahmoud Abbas I
believe that we are capable under your
leadership and your stewardship to your
courageous stewardship and your wisdom
we are as well as your great negotiating
ability but but the ass-kisser of the
month award and here it is exactly our I
have to be honest we had a thing called
the head up their ass over we've
repurposed it but hope Hicks the
spokesman for the White House Pope picks
this is something she wrote down this is
not an ad lib I'm going to not read it
all president Trump has a magnetic
personality and exudes positive energy
he has an unparalleled ability to
communicate with people he is brilliant
with a great sense of humor and this was
this was not the first draft of this we
got a hold of that it was even worse
would you like to hear it okay listen to
this
his dirty socks have the aroma of
lavender and his balls taste like
fresh-squeezed pineapple he can start
fires with his mind
what chooses not to to save jobs in the
matchstick industry he was born when
lightning struck a hundred-dollar bill
when he was in Jerusalem the Wailing
Wall slipped him a note the reason he
doesn't go to Camp David is because it
makes the horses insecure about their
penis size
he ejaculates magma which hardens to
form tropical islands where he builds
exquisite resorts
his ass is so big because it's full of
dreams for America
and women want him men want to be him
and men also want him even though they
know he's not into that but if he was he
be totally great at it
am i exaggerating that it's funny as
long as the movie we're watching is a
comedy but this is not really funny
right you get the sense the demand for
this kind of in Maine adulation is there
to prove that he's a big boy right
because he's a child Prince right like
it's like the driving as a
three-year-old right he's the boyfriends
running around to Europe touching the or
brand-new golf cart armwrestling
whatever and so the only way there's no
way you could rationally or with any
nuance praise his authority or
confidence so what you're left with and
what he must demand is this stupidity
you know when I was watching the
announcement the other day when he was
drew from Paris I had to turn it off
because of the the nature of these
introductions is too embarrassing to
watch but what strikes me is that you
have narcissism on steroids which is any
to something beyond we've ever seen
combined with a paranoia which is Nick
Sounion and the dystopian world view and
it's those three that mixed together
that create this completely dangerous
set of policies that he's inflicting
upon us and it's scary we spend a lot of
times talking to people in the Trump
what up so what's most interesting and
why this is so much a new form of
propaganda is that they're playing to an
audience of one when they're on TV they
know he spends an inordinate amount of
time watching TV he actually has like a
big TV and they communicate with him
through the - you watch this by
daydreaming and then doesn't like it in
ESPN or analyst saying how he did or
didn't do but here's what's interesting
is that you have when you talk to them
when they're not on camera they don't
pretend they don't talk like he's the
Dear Leader
they're super aware of the flaws that he
has in there very uncomfortable inside
the White House or it very they don't
trust him they don't trust that he has
daily her back but then you see it on
tonight's the brofist a leak
and the creepiest thing was when he got
Pruitt to come up in the Rose Garden
speech because it was so obvious and so
staged you know now Pruitt's going to
come up and say a few words and then
Pruett came up and said you're really
wonderful and it was like does he not
think that we noticed that he just did
that he truly thinks that nobody sees
his masterminding of the situation and
think that that sense that everybody out
there is so stupid is a sign of how
stupid he is but but the problem is that
he is a good decider and he made a
decision and the word has gotten out
even to the other world leaders the way
you get what you want is when you sit
down with them first tell them about how
the electoral victory we're all buzzing
about it in Ankara and then keep it
short because he's got the attention
span of a squirrel on meth so don't you
know I wish I agree with you about how
his being that stupid but the problem is
is we just said he won the election and
so the problem we got is that he did
outsmart us and somehow we're stuck with
the result I don't know if it was that
he outsmarted us we might have been as
stupid as he thought yeah oh you are one
way or another it ain't good
okay ting good